today's video has been made possible by
the forgotten city
if an open world mystery adventure game
based in a cursed
ancient roman city sounds interesting
then stick around
until the end to find out more
[Music]
um
oh
publius ovidius nasso or ovid to most of
us
a roman poet and the author of
metamorphoses
one of the great pieces of western
literature that has been translated
hundreds of times since its creation in
the 8th century
metamorphoses which means book of
transformations
details the history of the world from
its creation
all the way until the death of julius
caesar
in between there are hundreds of stories
based on the theme of metamorphosis
transforming it into something else
many of these stories are very similar
to their greek counterparts
but with a few slight changes today
we'll be taking a look at five stories
some of which are fairly well known and
others less so
[Music]
the first story today is the tragic tale
of callisto
i will be mentioning the roman names of
the deities that appear in today's
stories
but for the most part to make it easier
for everyone including myself
i will also be using their more common
greek names
the story begins with jove or zeus
scouring the land surveying the affairs
of men
in the woods his attention is caught by
a beautiful huntress
callisto the daughter of king ly cohen
callisto is described as a warrior of
diana
which means she was a devout follower of
artemis
or part of the cult of artemis the cult
of artemis valued nature
hunting and chest given artemis was a
virgin goddess when callisto found a
place to rest in the forest
she put down her bow and her spear
assuming his wife
juno or hera would never find out about
this
prank as ovid refers to it zeus appeared
to callisto
but not as himself instead he took the
form of
artemis when callisto saw her queen
before her she was
elated hail my queen greater than jove i
say
thou joe should hear normally zeus would
take great offense to a statement like
this
but he was delighted he had chosen the
right form to seduce callisto
when zeus made his advances his true
appearance was revealed
to callisto and she tried to fend him
off
but was unsuccessful once he was done
zeus retired to the heavens leaving
callisto to wander the forest distraught
at having broken her vow of chastity
zeus's plan to have this affair
disguised as
artemis was unsuccessful as hera had
seen
everything wandering through the forest
callisto came across
artemis once again but this time she was
hesitant
was this another of zeus's tricks
followed by her nymphs and
other companions callisto soon
recognized her patron goddess
she was invited to bathe in one of
artemis's sacred springs
which were known for their purity when
they reached the spring
and the nymphs confirmed that there were
no prying
eyes they undressed and entered the
water
the only person not to enter was
callisto
who could no longer hide her look of
shame eventually she was stripped
and her secret was revealed gazing upon
the shape of her body they could tell
she was bearing a child begone
diana cried you shall not stain my
stream
callisto bearing a child of zeus was
exiled from artemis's cult
everything she valued and had worked for
was taken from her
this was only the beginning of her
punishment sadly
hera who had observed everything was
waiting for the perfect time to take her
revenge
and that time was now when she saw
callisto had given birth to a boy
that was the final straw she grabbed
callisto by the hair and flung her to
the ground
callisto begged for mercy but these
prayers fell on deaf ears she held out
her arms and
hera laughed as those arms were covered
in thick fur
her nails began to grow the lips that
zeus lusted for became a hideous jaw
a transformation into a bear was now
complete
the only part of her that remained human
was her heart
so she could feel pain and heartbreak
when she wandered through the forest it
was now callisto being hunted
she would experience the horror of the
hunt as opposed to the thrill she
enjoyed so dearly
sixteen years later she came face to
face with a young
hunter she recognized her son
arcus when she tried to call out to
arcus
he saw nothing but a bear growling at
him
arcus took his javelin and just before
he unknowingly killed his mother
zeus would intervene he placed them both
in the sky as constellations
ursa major and minor in other variations
of this story
it ends with callisto being killed by
her own son
or artemis although there isn't too much
to be
happy about in the ovid's interpretation
at least it ends with mother and son
being reunited
in the kingdom of lydia the muses sung a
beautiful song of a young weaver known
as arachne her mother had passed away
and her father idmon of colophon was
known for his distinct
purple dye despite her humble upbringing
arachne's work was known in all of the
surrounding
kingdoms the muses themselves would
leave their home
just to watch arachne work one would
assume
she had been trained by palace herself
but arachne denied this claiming her
skill was her own
in this case palace refers to athena and
we know
she was the patron goddess of weaving
and crafting
this denial of athena was enough hubris
for her to pay arachne
a visit let her contend with me
should i lose there is no forfeit i will
not pay
athena transformed herself into an old
woman
and travelled to meet this remarkable
weaver
when she found her acne she gave some
advice
to always be humble and to ask for her
harsh words against the gods to be
forgiven
arachne's response is both arrogant
and provoking you're too old
your brain has gone you've lived too
long
the years have done for you talk to your
daughters
talk to your son's wives do not think
your words have
weight my own advice is all i need
why doesn't palace come by herself why
should she hesitate to match herself
with me having given arachne the chance
to apologize
this response is the final straw for
athena
she threw away her disguise and revealed
herself
the surrounding nymphs and women of
lydia all
knelt for their patron goddess and so
they agreed a contest to see
whose skills were superior athena's
tapestry
showed the olympians in all their glory
arachne's tapestry consisted of the same
gods and goddesses but instead she
detailed what she believed to be their
flaws if athena's peace painted the gods
in a positive light
arachnes was certainly negative and
displayed the same hubris which resulted
in this contest to begin with
inspecting arachne's work athena could
find no fault
the tapestry had been woven to
perfection
however its contents were a crime
against the heavens
athena tore the tapestry took the wooden
shuttle she had used during the contest
and struck arachne on the forehead after
the fourth strike
arachne could take the punishment no
longer she placed a noose around her
neck
but as she hung athena caught and raised
her
live yes
live but hang you wicked girl
and know you'll rue the future too
that penalty your kin shall pay to all
prosperity
athena sprinkled her with the drugs of
her carte
her hair began to fall out her nose and
ears followed
her head shrunk along with the rest of
her body
instead of arms and legs there were
eight long
fingers by her sides from her belly came
a fine spun
thread as a spider arachne could still
weave her web
forever pursuing the former skills she
once possessed
but always falling short in some
iterations of this story
arachne is somewhat of a sympathetic
character
but in ovid's story she is unlikable at
best
and it's very hard to argue her
punishment was unjustified
pygmalion was a renowned sculptor and a
king
in cyprus his experiences with women
were negative enough for him to take a
vow of celibacy
he still yearned for the companionship
of married love
but distracted himself with his work
he worked on a sculpture made from white
ivory
in the shape of a woman he thought to be
perfect
and more beautiful than any woman he'd
ever seen before
the more time he spent around the
sculpture the more he fell in love with
his own creation
the sculpture was so lifelike eventually
he could no longer distinguish between
what was real and what wasn't he would
have conversations
caress the sculpture and even dress her
as if she was real
the festival of venus or aphrodite
was a very big occasion in cyprus and
when it came
pygmalion saw an opportunity he made
several offerings to aphrodite at her
altar
afraid to discuss his secret out loud he
silently wished for a bride
just like his ivory woman when he
returned home
his prayers were answered the goddess of
love had transformed his ivory statue
into a real woman he finally had the
companionship and love he desired
as weird as his methods were pygmalion's
creation is never really given a name
in the years that followed the
sculpture-toned woman
would be known as galatea
from the tower the boy could only
imagine what it was like to be outside
daedalus felt a great sorrow for his son
whose childhood had been taken from him
he understood why minos had imprisoned
him for the role he played in aiding
theseus to slay the minotaur but poor
icarus didn't deserve to share in his
father's punishment
the tower was surrounded by water on all
sides
minos may own all else but he does not
own the air
daedalus gathered rows of feathers and
arranged them smallest first
followed by the larger ones he used
reeds to create a
shape that would imitate a bird's wings
and to hold it all together he used wax
when icarus saw his father's invention
he was overjoyed
fitting the wings daedalus instructed
his son
take care he said to fly a middle course
lest if you sink too low the waves may
weight your feathers
if too high the heat may burn them
fly halfway between the two and do not
watch the stars
set your course where i shall lead
as he inspected icarus's wings one final
time
he feared the worst he kissed his son
and jumped from the tower leading the
way icarus followed his father closely
but eventually he was distracted by the
stars
and flew too close to the sun the wax
started to melt
and the wings began to fall apart
daedalus could only watch helplessly as
his son
plummeted to his death he buried his son
on a nearby island that portion of the
sea
would forever bear icarus's name
our last tale goes by the name of
mercury and batus
the story of the theft of apollo's
cattle by
hermes the story begins with apollo in
his field
relaxing and playing music noticing him
not paying attention
hermes snuck into the meadow and stole
all of the
cattle hiding them in the forest there
was only one witness to this crime
an older man known as battis
hermes approached the man my good friend
whoever you are
if anyone inquires about this herd say
you've not seen them
and to thank you for that service take a
cow for your reward
and so hermes gave the man a cow
the man replied saying that stone over
there would tell
sooner than i having successfully bribed
the only witness to his crime hermes
disappeared into the forest
hermes however was no fall he returned
to test the old man's word
this time appearing with a completely
different voice
and build good fellow help me
if you've seen some cattle hereabouts
speak up
they are stolen and you shall have a cow
and a bull a pear this was double the
reward hermes offered
and as predicted the old man replied
there on yon hill they'll be
the man pointed to where hermes had
taken the castle
hermes nodded and laughed you
rogue you betray me to myself
me to myself i say
as the man previously stated that the
stone would sooner tell his secret
herme saw the humor in transforming the
man into stone
a stone that would be called telltale
a reminder for all those to see the
consequences
of treachery and that concludes today's
look at some of these stories from
ovid's metamorphoses if you would like a
second volume
with five more stories let me know your
thoughts in the comment section
as we mentioned earlier today's video
has been sponsored by the forgotten
city a game where you travel 2 000 years
into the past to a cursed roman city
where if even just one person sins they
all
die using different time loops it is up
to you to save everyone
and uncover the mysteries of the city
the forgotten city started off as a mod
that was downloaded over three million
times and due to the success it was
redesigned into a new genre as a
standalone
game if you enjoy murder mystery types
of games which are heavy on puzzle
solving and
exploration then i have no doubt that
you will enjoy this game
if you're a massive history buff or you
just enjoy ancient rome
you'll be glad to know the developers
have worked closely with multiple
historical experts
to make sure they have created a world
that feels authentic
from the art and architecture to the
clothing and
customs the aim was to make the player
feel like they were in
ancient rome if like me you're a huge
fan of mythological references and
easter eggs
you won't be disappointed a massive
thanks to modern storyteller and dear
villagers for reaching out and
supporting the channel
the game is available on steam and you
can purchase it today by using the link
in the description
or by searching for the forgotten city
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you